merci la parole est à monsieur jacques
pose-t-il merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre mais un autre ministre trouvera
certainement la réponse depuis 2013 la
cour des comptes demande régulièrement
que soit mis fin à la gratuité du passe
navigo pour les policiers résidant en
ile de france les magistrats de cette
institution s'appuie sur un décret de
2010 limitant à 50 % le remboursement
des titres de transport des
fonctionnaires transilien ce sont
plusieurs milliers d'agents de terrain
dépendant de la préfecture de police de
paris qui seraient concernées par cette
suppression du remboursement intégral
la convention qui lie l'état le syndicat
des transports d'ile-de-france va
arriver à échéance à la fin de cette
année nombre de policiers leurs
représentants syndicaux s'inquiète donc
d'une éventuelle modification du système
actuel et dans ce contexte il convient
de rappeler que ces agents non
sédentaires ont un statut spécial ils
sont contraints d'intervenir dans les
transports lors s'il constate un délit
ce qui est un élément sécurisant pour
les réseaux et les voyageurs et d'autre
part ils ont besoin de ce pass navigo
pour effectuer certaines de leurs
missions enfin compte tenu de la
modestie de leur rémunération en moyenne
1400 euros par mois il leur est
particulièrement difficile de trouver un
logement adéquat dans paris intra muros
pour ces raisons la prise en charge
complète des frais de transport paraît
légitime d'autant que le pass navigo va
connaître un dézonage s'accompagnant
d'un prix unique pour tous les
franciliens voire dans certains cas la
gratuité
alors plus que jamais nos fonctionnaires
de police ont besoin d'être soutenus et
aidés dans leur tâche
il me paraît très équitable que vous
trouviez une solution prolongeant après
la prise en charge de leurs frais de
transport en commun merci la parole est
à madame marylise lebranchu ministre de
la décentralisation et la crise merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
député de apporter une deuxième fois
dans la même séance soutien à nos
fonctionnaires
nous sommes en train de discuter avec
l'ensemble des ministères sur
l'accompagnement des affectations des
fonctionnaires qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
policiers gendarmes ou enseignants parce
qu'on a aussi les problèmes surveillants
de la pénitentiaire et qui correspond à
deux choses les indemnités de résidence
et effectivement les problèmes de
transport franchement je ne peux pas
imaginer qu'on supprime cet avantage
sans en trouver anneaux
nous sommes engagés avec l'ensemble des
ministères à regarder quel est le parc
de logements disponibles telles
conventions on peut passer parce que ce
que vous décrivez est exact pour les
policiers pour les autres comme je
disais à l'instant comment on peut
prendre en charge
effectivement les frais de déplacement
mais honnêtement si je suis seul dans
cette négociation
je l'attendrai d'abord d'avoir mis la
vie de mon collègue mais les à
l'intérieur je pense qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sur l'indemnité de résidence
adaptée au lieu dans laquelle on exerce
et surtout à notre parc de logement je
connais parce qu'on en a échangé avec
sylvia pinel des grandes difficultés
qu'on a aujourd'hui d'affecter des
logements à la fonction publique mais
pour ce qui concerne la sécurité et
l'éducation parce que c'est un problème
qui touche aussi beaucoup deux
enseignants il faut qu'on y arrive donc
je vous fais cet engagement et je
recevrai les syndicats avec plaisir
merci madame la ministre